Martin Amis has that written his memoir
a memoir called experience and it's
indeed a pleasure to have him here he's
been called many times at one of the
greatest novelists of his generation his
books are innovative and his prose is
candid and funny and incredibly
articulate and intelligent and I'm
always awed by his writing and I don't
think I need to introduce him any
further so without further ado I'm
Martin Amos
good evening how nice it is to see your
expectant faces I'm going to read a
passage featuring one a very
distinguished a resident of Washington
DC Christopher Hitchens and it's about
the time I took him to meet for the
first time Saul Bellow
but before I do that I just want to
summon my father's spirit into the house
if he were here tonight my father I know
exactly what he would say to me with
more reason than usual perhaps he would
say get your hair cut this is a little
scene between him and me get your hair
cut said Kingsley doggedly get your hair
cut there was no one else in the room
but he wasn't telling me to get my hair
cut over the years
Kingsley must have told me to get my
hair cut ten or twelve thousand times
but he wasn't telling me to get my hair
cut the air now was 1984 I was newly
married and there was a child on the way
I didn't need to get my hair cut
get your haircut get your haircut this
suggestion was being offered to the
television set more particularly to the
actress Linda Hamilton every time she
appeared on screen
we were watching a tape of the
Terminator again an old science fiction
hand King Z was a great fan of the
Terminator and seven years later he
would make no secret of his admiration
for terminator 2 a flawless masterpiece
according to him get your hair cut get
your hair cut in Terminator 2 1991 Linda
Hamilton wore her hair up or back in the
Terminator on the other hand she was
decidedly full meaned
as people were then in 1984 get your
hair cut get your hair cut I said I hope
you're going to stick with this Dan I
hope you weren't weakened if anyone
accuses you of being boring or
repetitive okay
because there are some I said who might
point out that this film has already
been made even if Linda Hamilton could
hear you and even if she thought it was
a good idea she couldn't go back and get
a haircut get your hair cut but don't
listen to them dad I said you you set
your stall out now it's up to you to see
this thing through
ya got after a while when the action
started and it became clear that Linda
Hamilton wouldn't have time or leisure
to get a haircut
Kingsley stopped telling her to get a
haircut now let's move on to mr.
Hitchens the the section is called
thinking with the blood the phrase of
Kipling's and it has to do you know
racial hatred Kipling defined as
thinking with the blood the section
within this chapter is called the hitch
New England 1989 Ravel Stein threw his
head back at this shutting his eyes he
flung himself bodily back into laughter
in my own way I did the same this is
quote across as I said before it was our
sense of what was funny that brought us
together but that would have been a pale
anemic way to put it a joyful noise he
meant so Jubilo an outsize joint
agreement picked up picked us up
together and it would get you nowhere to
try to formulate it I said in the car
the hired Chevrolet celebrity now no
sinister balls okay no sinister balls
he agreed promise promise my passenger
was Christopher Hitchens and I was
taking him to Vermont to meet Saul
Bellow we would have dinner and stay the
night and drive back to Cape Cod the
following morning Cape Cod was where I
spent eight or nine summers with my
first wife and with the boys on horse
leech pond south of wealthy the trope
sinister balls went back to our days at
the New Statesman during an interview
when we were short listing the new
editor
the writer nila Ashton said talking
about the unions which were very strong
at that time anyone who resists the
closed shop is going to get the biggest
bloody nose of all time he said and I
said afterwards that this was sinister
balls
and Christopher whether or not he agreed
certainly seemed to be taken by the
phrase so no sinister balls meant no
vehement assertions of a left-wing
tendency in 1989 temporary fluctuations
going under the name of political
correctness that rigged up Saul Bellow
as a figure of the right he was under
frequent attack and I felt that he
deserved a peaceful evening in his own
house as it happens I now believe that
Bello and Hitchens are not too similar
in their political intuitions especially
in their sense of how America is managed
or carved up when I read Christopher
Chris Christopher's book on Clinton no
one left a lie - I was physiologically
reminded of an hour I spent with Saul in
1988 I was on my way down to New Orleans
to cover the Republican convention where
Bush unleashed
Dan Quayle I remember the first thing
Quayle said in his new role as you know
possible vice president he took the
floor at some caucus and and said the
choice facing this country is whether we
go on to the future or past to the back
and Bush sure was making it even he
thought you know that well-known
assassin of the English language thought
Christ he attempted a cliche and even
messed that up
on this visit to the soil in Vermont I
requested a political tutorial to
prepare me for the convention Bella's
illusionists vision of beltway jobari
and pelf caused the hairs on the back of
my head to tingle as the Chevrolet
celebrity moved boldly down Route six I
was pretty confident that the evening
would go well there would be no sinister
balls a drive of five or six hours but
the buddy movie radion feel of the
journey was part of the tree stops were
made for the huge uneaten meals and many
powerful drinks des iterated by the
hitch at this time my friend was still
attached by one boot to the steer of his
midlife crisis which began in earnest at
the end of 1987 as commander Eric
Hitchens was going about the business of
dying
Christopher's younger brother Peter
revealed some family news the news was
that they were both Jewish and their
mother had kept it a secret and she died
tragically young and it was the
grandmother who who told them the truth
this information provoked a complicated
sort of pleasure and was certainly a
stimulus but it all come hard upon
realignments of mother death of father
the two ammar goes now transfigured
amarga is a nice psychological word
meaning meaning the child's image of the
parents and the first marriage
separation from children and here he was
turning 40 as a member of a different
race I will always regret that I was a
lesser friend to Christopher in his
climacteric
than he was to me in mine when it came
true he already knew the ground he had
experienced the main events including
divorce which I was still and I was
still a few years behind in filling out
what Saul Bellow calls the pain schedule
quote the hardest items of all have to
do with love
unquote Christopher and I in leaving
home did what we did for love but how
does it look the love ledger by the time
you're done because you were also the
enemy of love and for your children is
Despoiler I hate love said my son Louie
at the age of five or six he was
complaining about the excessive love
interest in a book we were reading I
hate love he didn't mean that
but he could now say I no longer trusted
when Dryden retold the story of Antony
and Cleopatra
he called his tragedy or for love or the
world well lost those stupendous
sweethearts sacrificed empires but they
were certain that love the primary value
was being exalted even in their defeats
and their suicides I envied them the
flourish we who had sent ourselves from
the daily company of our children must
reckon it differently love comes out of
it with gains but also with losses and
whenever love is losing the force of
death makes gains divorce the incredibly
violent thing as my father put it what
parent involved in it has not wished for
the death of the once loved one this is
universal and this is why your heart
feels gangrenous inside your chest this
is why as I put it to myself you want
men in white to come and take away take
you away and wash your blood the cream
celebrity moves softly on through the
high morale farmlands and pastures of
New Hampshire and into the unscoped
Atlantis Cape of Vermont when the when
the roads got darker and twistier and we
paused again in a high tunnel of orange
foliage to buy the several bottles of
wine nominated by the hitch and seconded
by me the bellows a generous hosts and
Saul knew John Barrowman and Delmore
Schwartz famous alcoholics but they
could have no conception of what they
faced here
bust plenty of honey and maple syrup to
take back to Cape Cod signaling left the
celebrity turned off the main road and
down into the valley
the bellows were waiting in their garden
at about 11:15 that night a silence
slowly elongated itself over the over
the dinner table
Christopher utterly sober but with his
eyes lowered was crushing in his hands
an empty packet of Benson & Hedges the
bellows two had their gazes downcast I
sat with my head in my palms staring at
the aftermath of the dinner that
evenings road smash with its buckled
headlights its yawning hinges its still
oscillating hubcap my right foot was
injured because I kicked the shins of
the hitch so much with it foot note
against the hitch physical and
intellectual opposition are equally
futile when in the 1970s he left the New
Statesman we would all soon leave it for
the bourgeois broadsheet The Daily
Express
I went mano-a-mano with him among the
sawdust and [ __ ] smoke and bum crack of
an infernal Irish pub in a basement of
Piccadilly Circus I was in the unusual
position of attacking Christopher from
the left for defection for betrayal for
taking the Richmond shilling sadly
watched by James Fenton the poet on our
colleague our wills my will and the will
of the hitch became concentrated in the
glass we were both holding with our
right hands it was a wineglass and it
contained a single whiskey we were
squeezing it while looking implacably
into each other's eyes squeezing it so
that began to creak I'd assisted I
climbed down because I suddenly knew
that he would not desist not in a
million years and when we went off to
casualty together the hitch would have
no no
Gretz no regrets about that gashed palm
that missing finger lost in the sawdust
none
later that year James and I and
Christopher would journey by trained
together to cover the Conservative Party
conference in Blackpool the Express had
installed the hitch at the Grand with
its view of the Irish Sea James and I
were in a fiver a night bed and
breakfast up some distant backstreet now
that's being left-wing you lie awake on
your narrow cot listening to the only
other piece of furniture in the room the
hulking wardrobe as the Beatles eat it
it would be a simplified simplification
to say that Christa Christopher had
spent the last 90 minutes talking up a
blue streak of sinister balls we're back
at the dinner table now but let us not
run in fear of [ __ ] of simplification
simplification is sometimes exactly what
you want the theme of discord was of
course Israel
Christopher was already on record with a
piece called Holy Land heretic where he
had deduced quote the generalized ideal
I idealizations of Israel commonly
offered by Saul Bellow Elie Weisel and
others unquote much of Christopher's
discourse at the dinner table in Vermont
can be found in this eight thousand word
essay which he wrote so to speak as a
Gentile and the rest of his discourse
can be found in on not knowing the half
of it which he wrote as a Jew needless
to say it was a point of fundamental of
elementary intellectual honor that
Christopher Christopher's changed
ethnicity ethnicity should have no
effect whatever on questions of
political science and political morality
grant the disclosure that he was Jewish
had not rendered Israel any less
messianic or expansionist or quasi
democratic Christopher would do no
thinking with his blood neither at the
desk nor at the dinner table
emotions atavisms would be set aside
while reason that prints of all the
faculties went about its word saw was on
record to at book lengths in to
Jerusalem and back in his journalism his
essays and Jewishness is close to the
hub of the wheel of his fiction which is
another way of saying that it evades his
unconscious mind it would be pointless
to deny that on the question of Israel
bellow to some extent thinks with the
blood the unconscious always thinks with
the blood if the right writer is made up
of three things
literary being innocent everyman then
the innocent is very strong in Saul
Bellow despite great learning experience
and mouse this is how he does it as a
writer he runs everything past his
innocence his never mind his first soul
he runs everything past his soul the
blood thinks that Israel therefore is
bound to him by consanguinity quote
Jewish consanguinity and archaism which
the Jews until the present century
stopped them were in the course of
divested themselves unquote Israel is
consanguineous with Exodus and diaspora
with pogrom ghetto and Holocaust I once
said Saul say that the Jews would have
been finished without Israel after the
beating they're taken the next chapter
would be assimilation and that would be
the end of it that would be the end of
the connection to all the significant
dead naturally bellow was capable of a
rational discussion of Israel pros and
cons but it wasn't that kind of evening
no it wasn't that kind of evening very
soon jannis the Saul's wife and I were
reduced to the occasional phoneme of
remonstration
and saw pack down over the table
shoulders forward legs tents beneath his
chair became more laconic in his
contributions steadily submitting to a
cataract of Pure Reason
Christopher's cerebral spam peed then it
was over and we faced the silence my
right foot throbbed from the warm work
it had done beneath the table on the
shins of the hitch availing me nothing
as I should explain I to think about
Israel with the blood but my blood
wasn't thinking about Israel not then a
consensus was forming in the room
silently that the evening could not be
salvaged a change of subject and a
cleansing cup of coffee know nothing for
it now but to finish up and seek our
bedding but for the time being we sat
there rigid as the silence raged on
Christopher was still softly compacting
his cigarette packet he seemed to be
giving it this job his full attention
before him in the silence they were
stilled battlefield the State of Israel
thoroughly outmaneuvered comprehensively
overthrown in his clef a short leash
novel of London literary life brilliant
creatures like James said of the
Hitchens based character that the phrase
no wit abashed might have been invented
for him but Christopher did not seem to
be entertaining the conception of self
reproof during the argument the opinion
the opinions of Professor Edward Sayid
had been weighed and this is what
Christopher enclosing wish to emphasize
the silence still felt like a gnat in my
ear well said Christopher I'm sorry if I
went on a bit but Edward is a friend of
mine and if I hadn't defended him I
would have felt bad how'd you feel now
said so
there's now a digression where I talk
about why I think about Israel with the
blood it's because my first love was a
Jewish girl and a virgin and during the
six-day war she went off frantically to
give blood for Israel so I think about
Israel with the blood not my blood but
the blood of my first love it's all Gala
tends to Beach if this is called death
of a feeling this last section Saul
Bellow tends to be cheerful in the
morning and will normally give you a
couple of numbers over the toast and
cereal
kakuka Katie for instance and if there
are children to be entertained the one
about a Hogan's goat unsurprisingly
perhaps there were no songs no Nursery
Rhymes to be heard as Christopher
pausing to extinguish a cigarette in the
fireplace reoccupied his spot of the
table breakfast was polite he and I
didn't linger and soon we were staring
off into the mist and the eastern
woodlands on the way back to the Cape IX
acted the phrase is James fentons
an sbir a small but interesting revenge
I didn't see my stunt as a repeated act
not at the knot of the time for our
return journey was marked by the usual
fraternal ease I thought I was merely
surrendering to some juvenile impulse
now I clearly apprehend that I did in
fact want satisfaction somewhere in
rural Massachusetts we took the
necessary break for the many powerful
drinks and the huge uneaten meal without
which the hitch could not long subsist
it was when we crossed the bridge and
joined route 6 gaining the Peninsula of
the Cape the Christopher began to press
the case not for a repartition Jerusalem
but for an immediate rest stop
the cream celebrity build on after
another 20 minutes or so by which point
Christopher's whimpers have become a
steady wine for mercy he reminded me of
my sons and their terminal cry dad quick
I'm desperate I veered onto a slip road
and at 60 miles per hour ground my sole
right foot into the into the brake pedal
the bladder of the hitch so intimately
peach and trice tin the seatbelt
jackknife forward and then even more
horribly twanged back into its bucket I
find it difficult to duplicate the
double groan he gave approximately at
that as alarm quickly modulated into the
most earnest suspense and he remained
resolutely unamused by the incident when
he came back from the drenched Spinney
and I in my turn slipped into it the
shrub the scrub the butt-ends the air
always tangy with the gasps of human
relief the hitch attempted finessing
getaway in the celebrity abandoned
abandoning me to a walk of I guess
several miles as it turned out he
couldn't make the car start
that evening in the house on horse each
pond Christopher and I had our longest
and loudest laughing fit ever followed
by our longest and loudest fight the
laughing fit I will return to the fight
was predictable and had to come I said
so so you were defending your friend
your friend Edward well Edward wasn't
there the friend who was there was me
what about that friend and what about my
friend and you were doing that horrible
thing with your lips you know when he's
sort of making you but he's really
putting some and darling so listen and I
then broaden my fire a reigning
Christopher as the cause of the recent
upheavals in his life there are times
though when manners are more important
than the State of Israel just as as
there was a time in Israel I was having
a violent argument about nuclear weapons
with Allan bloom when when manners were
more important than the end of the world
I climbed down life just here is
behaving like a short story and
everything is connected everything is
connected or for love the world well
lost the deaths of feelings
Christopher was coming to the end of a
world with great shiftings massive
rearrangements all the Ammar goes all
the picture cards the face cards were
being shuffled king and queen and jack
on the phone the next day still shocked
indignant and guilty I was saying and
tell Janice I'm sorry
please don't worry about it so it's all
you deserved a night off I thought Saul
was emphatic Martin you're not to be
hard on yourself about it thank you I
said but when you bring listens that's
all I'm used to it I get that kind of
thing all the time and I said that's
what the hate said in self exculpation
is that I gets it all the time we
couldn't avoid laughing at that and
accordingly the case began to close some
summers later I was in the same kitchen
in Vermont when Christopher sent the
bellows an apology or at least a thank
you note in ciphered in a piece
he published in the London Review of
Books the communication was leniently
know warmly received and so was my wife
a different wife who came with me on
that later visit and I was reared in my
new reality it is a simple desire to try
and to triangulate your friends and I'm
ready on this one to go in again what
gives the thing justice is that it was
Hitchens who introduced me to Bello as a
reader look at humbles gift he told me
with a serious inclination of the head
on the staircase of the New Statesman in
1977 I looked instead at the victim and
after very few pages I felt a
recognition threading itself through me
whose form of words more solemn and
exhilarated went approximately as
follows here is a writer I will have to
read all of everything else followed
from this and it remains the basis of
the connection
I see Bello perhaps twice a year and we
call me right but that accounts for only
a fraction of the time I spend in his
company he is on the shells on the desk
he is all over the house and always in
the mood to talk that's what writing is
not communication but a means of
communion and here are the other writers
who swirl around you like friends
patient intimate sleeplessly accessible
over centuries this is the definition of
literature
oh yes that laughing fed it was the kind
of paroxysm that turns you inside out
and leaves you with a new set of bodily
fluids it meant so juban Jubilo the joke
the improvisation had nothing to do with
Israel or Vermont but we are still in
this short story and everything measures
up in one of his most stunning
utterances Nietzsche said that a joke is
an epigram on the death of a feeling
it's awfully good that footnote when
Princess Diana died it took four or five
days for the jokes to marinate when John
Kennedy jr. died the jokes were
instantaneous electronic light
speed the feeling in other words had no
chance to exist it was born dead one
wonders - about subsequent roadkill on
the information highway back to the text
our improvisation was violently
scatological I would not survive
transcription but feelings were being
mourned feelings about the first half of
life youth can perhaps be defined as the
illusion of your own durability the
final evaporation of the solution
parches the skin beneath the eyes and
makes your hair crackle to the brush it
was over there would be held to pay
dying sons of a certain size perform the
alchemists nightmare they turned gold
into lead and there we were in 1989
heading towards base metal transmutation
had come to him that would soon come to
me but here for a little while longer is
the house on horse each pond here are
the trees where Christopher and I at the
age of 36 stood posing for photographs
with our sons in our arms
Lois Alexander the women taking the
photographs were Antonia and Eleni and
there would be other births Jacob Sofia
all this is going to go all this is
going to disappear this will fail I will
fail I said to myself look at it look at
what you've done there's the rented car
a different rented car in which you will
drive alone to Logan there's your wife
crying and drive beyond her are your
boys on the patch of grass with that zoo
of theirs the frogs the Turtles thank
you very much
I'd be happy to answer any questions you
might have
you want another bit know the shortage
bit okay Oh doors he thinks he came out
wonderfully well and he did it with him
later well I'll just read a little bit
about my childhood
despite tenacious inaccuracy
inaccuracies in the press and despite my
sister's sister Sally's birthplace
Swansea and middle name my family and
despite the ridicule of my son's quote a
Welshman through-and-through born in the
heart of Wales to Holy Welsh parents who
can trace their Welsh lineage back to
unquote and despite having very short
legs which is a Welsh thing you know
some Welsh people are the same height
sitting down and standing up and some
Welsh people are taller sitting down
this anagram I can lean it no claim to a
single drop of Welsh blood nonetheless
in the novel night train I spent the
first 12 years and my life in in Swansea
in Wales and I've read in Wales recently
and I was someone said accused me of in
Night Train I said that schadenfreude ER
the languid contemplation of the
miseries of others was not a German word
but a Welsh one and someone spoke up
they aren't from the Welsh boxer who
know no they don't
I'm from the West Boxing Association
they don't take you up that he's
strongly on it and I said I I said I
know you turn off frightening you CAF's
you know I spent 12 years here I know
what you're like and there's a huge
storm of recognition when I read this
out to them
this is a schatten frightened once
driving down the mumbles Road along the
coast the family encountered a traffic
jam caused by a serious accident in the
car there was a murmur of anxiety that's
Annie then two years old or three might
see something frightening finally we
approach the crossroads they're on the
verge was a twitching blood bespattered
figure half covered by an old overcoat
and Welsh nanny Eva was in the back of
the car we seem to be safely past when
either propped sally up on the back seat
and said look at him son driving in
agony is
and here's another bit of Eva Eva can I
have a glass of milk with my lunch Eva
was wedged into her chair by the Rayburn
a squat black argA and I saw her legs
swing up for purchase and then and then
relax and then resettle again she had
been going to say yes but now she said
no no she said oh why not I said she
said because I knew a man who had a
glass of milk with his lunch and he died
I was sure that this was nonsense and
perfunctory nonsense - she was just
generally succumbing to a rare attack of
laziness all the same until I was an
adult I avoided glasses of milk at
lunchtime in case I died and once I was
an adult the question of having a glass
of milk with my lunch simply stopped
coming up thanks very much thanks
so I like the way you integrated Philip
Larkin home livings and one of your
swords a narrative in describing your
resistances elsewhere you talked about
Craig rain are there any poets do you've
learned not as much from over maybe
maybe new a compliment
yes I mean you know what poets do is
father was a poet as well as a novelist
and that that's the main difference
between the two of us and I mean what
poets do is they slow they slow the
world down and freeze it and then
examine it with you know in a language
where where every word has to count and
pay its way whereas I feel I'm I'm
caught I don't really want to slow
things down that much and if I do get a
kind of poetic notion then I don't write
a poem about it I write a paragraph
about it
and that was why my father had trouble
with my prose because he felt it was too
worked out in dr. Johnson's phrase it's
sniffed of the lamp in other words I'd
stayed up too late with it you know and
wiggled it around but I think um poets
give you a not a novelist gives you a
world view poets don't do that they they
give you a view of an individual heart
and the Australian poet Gita Porter used
to be a colleague of mine at the tls and
I once said to him I'd written a couple
of poems and published a couple of poems
my father used to taunt me about it and
say I don't seem to see your first book
of poems
rather puzzling the puzzling absence of
your first book of poems and I said
Peter what you need to do to write poems
he said you need to be able to listen to
your own heart and I I thought well
that's something I can't do but of
course you can do that in a in a
different kind of way in a novel but
it's no you come away from poets with
the impression of a tremendous
individual rather than and with
novelists something a bit more Universal
and we now live at the time alas I think
because like my father I always regarded
poetry as the higher form it goes poetry
fiction drama but I think the novel is
is somehow overtaking the poem now and
that the the bigger figures are are
novelists not poets alas perhaps you
know this tells us something about
ourselves so if a if a boast one can ask
a question to ask us to see there's more
that the influence of your father on
your body we you always have very
different styles was it was just in any
sense of conscience or very unconscious
reaction I think I am I purged his
influence by imitation rather than
rebellion but the only practical little
advice he ever gave me and I was quite
slow to take it was um we were talking
about his first published story called
the sacred Rhino of Uganda written when
he was 12
and I said what was it like and he said
oh he said terrible in the usual sorts
of ways but also terrible in that full
of false quantities and I said like what
he said oh you know raging and cursing
in the blazing heat and I said I said
what's wrong with that I mean I see is a
bit old-fashioned he said we can't have
three ings like that he said it has to
be raging and cursing in the intolerable
heat and I went upstairs and looked at
the type spirit of my first novel and
came downstairs and said is my novel is
doggerel it's you know hickory dickory
dock the clock the cat ran up the clock
or whatever it is he said I'm sure
you're exaggerating and I went and had
another look at it and it was full of
that kind of thing and he said you can't
it's the same went for preferences as
well as suffixes so you couldn't had
lots of shuns in a sentence you couldn't
have lots of pries in a sentence or
prose as a prefix and that that was
about the you and I observe that and
it's a very important part of euphony
not to have the word you know you
obviously don't write the cook took a
look at the book or standing on the
landing but you also purge it of these
repeated preferences and suffixes and
that was a good lesson sir
mention slowing time down where where
did the concept of pipes arrow come from
the idea baton sense of the world this
is a question about Chinese era web the
narrative runs backward in time like a
like a newsreel turn around and so you
know most disconcerting me that the
Holocaust becomes a kind of holy miracle
because you are creating a race out of
the skies and then you know taking them
on trains and putting them in houses and
it's an act of restoration which is in
fact in a way chimes with Nazi ideology
they thought they were healing something
they thought they would it was a
biomechanical vision but the idea came
from from the physical universe it's
just this last week being established
that the universe is flat but if it if
it had not been flat then you would get
if it had been I think the word is
closed you would get what they call the
80 billion year heartbeat most
head-spinning idea that the universe
would expand until the the force of the
original explosion gave out and then it
would start if there was enough matter
in the world it would start to contract
until you ended up with what they call
the Big Crunch and in that world in that
phase time would run backwards and so
would like and and that's where the
notion came from I read recently that
several British novelists have decided
to
in the united states i can't pass there
every whether you would want one of the
ones that was mentioned but regardless
what you think accounts for this well
the salman rushdie is the preeminent
example and i think he wanted a freer
life than they'd let him live in england
and he can do that here we think we hope
one minor element would have been to
escape the the british press which has
been you know tirelessly vicious about
him for the last ten years because it's
taxpayers money see and he's a foreigner
and writer too they don't like them
either
and that's almost worse than being a
foreigner being writer and there was Ian
Foster who said that women ensure our
women and children was the phrase that
the English mail used to signal his
departure from sanity but now it's
taxpayers money
that'll do but he came over here and and
and faced a murderous campaign from the
New York Post the Murdoch paper which
had pictures of him with a you know with
a telescopic sights crosshairs on it on
the front page so that hasn't you know
that that bit hasn't worked out but much
else has I think I probably will follow
him in a couple of years when my
children at University and what brings
me here what would bring me here is
actually is is totally it's for artistic
reasons that there is just more stimulus
here England is you know it's in a way
the most evolved country on earth had
its revolution a century earlier than
anyone else and you know got on with it
and it's now evolved into a kind of
European efficiency state like Israel I
cope not Israel Switzerland and as
Christopher put it in a politically all
the piss and vinegar has gone out of it
whereas America is more like a world
than a country
Saul Bellow said and there's no danger
of the piss and vinegar going out of it
here at the back man I'm washing the
question for you boom you amused or did
you take pity on Christopher when he
turned Sidney Sidney Blumenthal into the
compression was i amused or distressed
when Christopher signed the affidavit on
Sidney Blumenthal well Sid is a friend
of mine too not as close to friend as as
Christopher I thought I was worried
about it until I read Christopher's book
and then I thought
Christopher's book made me think I'd
been getting really screwed over by
Clinton and that all of you had been you
know with with utter cynicism he had
been he'd been just you know massaging
his own interests and career and I felt
that that retrospectively justified it
up to a point you know it was the only
thing he could do to hurt Clinton and he
knew he would get murdered in the press
for doing it you know as I know to my
cost
there's the sacrifice or evidence
sacrifice of parent sacrifice of a
friendship is that a very poor view of
that is taken by the souls and
Jonathan's of the press each to each and
Achilles Patroclus we know what Paragons
of loyalty they are but it gives it it
gives them a very good excuse because
they make it look as though you did it
you know
utterly blithely and cynically you
sacrifice the friendship but no
Christopher knew what he was you know
what he would get in response and I
talked to him a week after he did it and
he said I'm in a world of pain he said
but he knew he's going to get there and
he and he
took that on he thought I'm going to do
it because it's the only way I can have
attention and that was what he very
badly wanted to do
excuse me wasn't the only one hurt
clipped to his dead birth administration
was putting out for lie and Blumenthal
was disseminating about
Monica Lewinski Davis pellicer which he
wants to expose the cordilla press but
what it loves that's true
but I mean we're going to need ours if
you're going to talk this one through so
that it move on check in this town madam
um yes I loved Nightrain and I liked
that you wrote from a woman's point of
view and I think both you and your
father have received some criticism
some feminists criticism and I just
wondered if you were happy with the
result of writing
and I thought you did a great well thank
you um I'd written from a woman's part
of this night rain I'd written from a
woman's point of view before in London
Fields and and a whole novel other
people but this was first person woman
and that you know I really got a sense
that when you go from he to I or she to
I you really zoom in you your focus
takes you right in it and it's utterly
different from writing the third but I
think you know I've got it I got into
trouble in the past for saying that men
and women are different no longer a very
controversial thing to say I think that
but for a little while you couldn't say
that and I said they were about as
different as the French are from the
English you know women hold cup warm
drinks with both hands have you noticed
that and when they're driving they they
lean when they go round corners that
sort of thing also they blame you for
anything bad you do in their dreams I
says not my your dream and she said if I
wouldn't have had the dream if you've
been nice nicer but it turns out in
writing when all is going well that the
gap between the sexes is a rut which any
frog could straddle there's no distance
and in art we're equivalent and
androgynous and it was it was a lovely
holiday from being a man to write that
book
was it a holiday to return to memoir or
fiction is it very different to turn
from memoir to fiction it's so different
that my metabolism was utterly
transformed by I realized later I
thought I was just it was another you
know coot of years I just I was going to
be like that from here on in I thought
when he turned fifty blame blame
everything on age but the difference was
that I I couldn't get out of bed in the
morning I was having the most gorgeous
Lions I've ever had in my life and when
I did get out it how fast twelve I think
I could do another three or four hours
and they and be like one of my sons you
know coming out of 5:30 in the afternoon
you remember that sort of teenage calf
are when it took you all day to move one
sock from from one end of your bed
bedroom to the other and that would be a
highly productive day but it wasn't that
I was dreading getting to work and in
fact I wrote this book you know but more
than twice the rate I would write
fiction
it was just pure emotional exhaustion
and I would say to myself it was quite
you know Pleasant emotional exhaustion
but I would say to myself while I was
writing that I couldn't conceivably
write a novel in this state in this sort
of lugubrious lachrymose stage but again
not unpleasant emotion but too much
emotion to get any art done so enormous
difference and when I finish I finished
the book I was again quite deedily
waking up at 9:30 in the morning with my
head full of words and sentences and the
difference is I think that I wrote this
with my conscious mind and and half the
work had been done for me because I
lived it and when I finish it I felt the
unconscious was plugged in again that
you know stuff from the back of the mind
was active and that's where the novels
come from not from your essay istic
forehead but from the nape of your neck
your central nervous system man you talk
about your politics and how they relate
to your politics well I'm I'm writing in
fact next as short as her pamphlet
length political political peace kind of
a memoir but mostly about attitudes to
communism and communism itself and I
traced this through my father who was a
communist until 56 not a card-carrying
one until the end of the war but he was
comrade Amos at Oxford and Iris Murdoch
was comrade murder yeah it's amazing
also the fact that some a figure who has
been around in my past and is and is
still around and pleased to say his
Robert conquest the poet historian
described in a 1989 plenum of the
Central Central Committee in Moscow as
anti Soviet chick number one who is in
Russia as a sort of soldier almost a
sergeant
Solzhenitsyn sized figure for his work
on the the terror and the famine and
other books and then I'm trying this in
with the fact that Christopher Hitchens
and James Fenton in those New Statesman
days were proselytizing trotskyists and
Christopher course says I stand by every
word I wrote about that in those days
you know and still believes that Lenin
is a great man which he most definitely
was not so it's and it's about the great
lacunae in the West in Western thought
then with such fascinating cruces as the
the correspondence between Nabokov and
Edmund Wilson which you note says it all
in a way there's Wilson with his
romantic view of Lenin and
and starstruck by Trotsky and there is
not a cough who had what a fantastic
life he had in a Russian Revolution
escape during the First World War where
does he go to but the line' where his
father is assassinated in 1922 his
father's described by Trotsky very
isolated saying your height that correct
with his dry self-satisfaction Trotsky
write writes he was finally killed in
Berlin in 1932 marvelous that finally
isn't it said the bloodthirsty you know
Trotsky wanted him dead and finally
someone had killed it killed him then
then not a cough lived in Berlin
throughout the rise of Hitler and the
accession to power of Hitler and was
very bravely and ostentatiously
patronized Jewish shops during the the
bans on doing that then he left on the
last boat from art of France as as
France collapsed of the Nazis in 1940
with his Jewish wife and their son and
then had the life of a you know an
American immigrant an amazing historical
life so he in this correspondence with
Edmund Wilson pounds on and on and says
you know all you're seeing in Russia
this was been in the 40s is changes in
the day core that screens are more or
less unchanging black abyss of
repression and terror and meanwhile
Wilson nursed his illusions into the
grave and even in his revision of to the
Finland station in nineteen seventy said
I made I mean I may have been a bit easy
on then and I think he was rather ruder
than I thought he was and then bizarrely
goes on about the murder of the of the
Czar and his family as if as you know
that as if that is morally more
significant than
all the other murders conquest book the
harvest of sorrow says in the first
paragraph to get some this is about the
Terra Famine of 1932 deliberate famine
the enforced famine that Stalin visited
on the Ukraine and Kazakhstan and
elsewhere and conquest begins but by
saying to get some idea of what we are
dealing with in this book you must be
aware that 20 human lives were lost not
for every word but for every letter in
this book and the book is 400 pages long
and it's the only book on that subject
the lacunae is that you know the
Holocaust is where it is and where it
should be and the Russian experience
needs to approach that I think we have
poutine minting coins with Stalin's face
on it and then having a tea with the
Queen
whereas Hyder praises Austrians Hyder
praises one one Hitlerite policy and is
immediately spat out like a bad oyster
from Europe that's too much of a
disproportion I mean I'm not a political
being I'm not I'm not accepting you know
all the other right-wing packages that
go with this but I think it's just a
question of the truth and that's what I
want to write next give your friends of
the soul fellow what is your impression
is
fictionalized portrayal
in rapid T but I think rather seen is
absolutely credible book and should be
celebrated on the grounds of its
uniqueness I don't think we've heard
fiction of that power from someone of
that age that Vantage and the prose has
a tremulous and crystallized beauty and
music that the world has never heard
before
you know I say in this book that I am
Saul's ideal reader and what I mean by
that is when I read the book for the
third time
recently I was finishing it and I just
thought no one can be getting more out
of this than I am NOT but I challenge
anyone to get as much out of this as I
work that's with a couple more yes madam
a really wonderful essay on Larkin
I have a virgin book yet
but I've loaded into ever intended
this is a fair bit about Larkin in this
book and in fact you know it's the poets
that I knew whom I quote more than the
knock door novelists that I was
surprised by how much the my book is
sort of studied with quotes from the
poets and you know what an incredible
luxury it is to have these poets in your
past and Larkin wrote a pair of my
little sister called born yesterday and
you know that greatly enriched her life
I think it is it is a luxury to have
them the poet's so the back monix New
York Times there's a discussion or
questions why the three senior writers
were written books fellow Roth and
uptight recently that have been well
praised well received
listen to articles in The New Yorker and
everywhere and yet their sales are way
off they do not match the critical
rephrase nor the particles and
complicity and the writer tries to
wrestle with why why does he come up
with the writer it seems a little
simplistic but the suggestion is got
through buyers of books are nothing
people in gentling in this room but
they're much younger people and the
younger people do not have the same
sensitivities in the same sense of
things that the older people that have
lived with mellow and often uptight for
fifty years
Wow right well that's that was probably
a lot in that but what Roth said
recently is that um that he feels is
right his readers are dying
maybe that simple horrible thought I
hope you don't die